how you doing people this is the Reuben
report
I'm the rebel leader in the war on
Christmas Dave Rubin I have the elf
commander Ben mankiewicz and the woman
who invented candy canes and a Kasparian
with me how was that that was pretty
good I almost went with you with candy
canes and you were gonna be a leader I
was a little I thought well that's cute
anis the elf commander and then it
turned out I'm the elf not not anyway
and the inventor of candy canes I read
that sounds sort of sexual but I meant
that who doesn't like the candy cane
people all right we got a lot to get to
so let's do it so about one minute ago
according to our time the interview have
you heard about the interview this
little film that's upsetting the people
in North Korea it apparently debuted on
YouTube you can download it or stream it
for apparently six bucks and it has
become pretty obvious to me that this is
the biggest and best publicity stunt of
all time so I want to start with our
movie man is was this whole thing know a
setup no no it wasn't a setup but
there's a tremendous amount of
dishonesty in it and and just you should
always look at what powerful people say
were they careful i the the president of
Sony Entertainment who said after
Obama's press conference when the
president said Sony should have released
it and he went what was I supposed to do
and someone was like well you what about
on the first one he didn't just
apologize he said essentially we stood
firm we did not back down we were ready
to fight and stand up for freedom and
you really want to release the movie on
the internet yeah and by the way for the
record Sony which owns PlayStation is a
streaming service and I'm pretty sure
they don't crackle to manage to figure
out how to get it on YouTube yeah I
guess what it just like initially Sony
had called YouTube and YouTube wouldn't
take their calls I'm pretty sure that if
Sony wanted this movie out they could
have had it out and then of course they
also didn't do the other thing in their
principled standing up yeah which was
call the theaters back and say please
don't
or call smaller theaters or make any
attempt whatsoever obviously they were
very
Tribble pulling the movie but no I don't
think it was a publicity stunt it didn't
it didn't need a publicity stunt and
it's fraught with gigantic peril so if
it's not a publicity stunt though
doesn't the threat still stand the idea
that you know the hackers said we're
gonna do some kind of night like that
still stands right I mean if you freaked
out about every anonymous threat that
was issued online then everyone would be
in a constant state of panic right after
the show right right I mean I'm getting
12 terroristic threats right now as I
speak right so I never really thought
that anyone was facing any imminent
danger due to this movie I'm still
really skeptical about North Korea being
behind the hack but one thing that I
will say you know just commenting on
Ben's commentary there's something
really admirable about people saying you
know what we made a decision the
decision was wrong and we've changed our
minds but instead people want to pretend
as though they were on the right course
from the very beginning they weren't on
the right course okay they totally
wussed out they deleted all social media
accounts that were related to the
interview they canceled all screenings
they canceled all interviews at James
Franco and Seth Rogen were supposed to
do James Franco Franco we don't know I
believe nobody
do you think Mary so forgetting
conspiracy I'll go with your no
conspiracy fine however do you think
that there this was like a little test
for the industry at least of going ah
maybe we start doing this simultaneous
YouTube streaming thing with less
theaters you know like some shift in how
they operate they'll certainly be
interested in in how this does and then
they have to factor in how this does
related to you know how much hype was
there a lot of people you to guys guess
weren't planning on seeing the movie I
saw it you know I've seen I've seen it
yeah I mean nobody else in America is
more than 10 minutes in right now let me
tell you exactly what happened it's
pretty funny it's a little stupid it
goes too far at times I think James
Franco is the weak link in it just
because that sort of Ron Burgundy like
character it
to be a little more or maybe a little
less but he was sort of in between on
buffoonery and it doesn't doesn't work
but seth rogen is pretty good and it's a
kind of an interesting it's funny it's
funny they made a comedy they make
basically good comedies and this is this
is this is one of them I think that that
when you see it and you realize that
this was the touchstone for sort of
standing up for artistic freedom that's
gonna strike people it's a little
puzzling they're funny guys and they
made a pretty funny movie yeah so final
thought on this to your point do you
kind of think that cyberwar is scarier
than real war that's thinking like I'm
not worried that anyone's gonna hit us
with a missile I'm really not pretty
much nobody is shooting a missile at us
but there was like a 24-hour window
where it really seemed like we were
taking away our own freedoms because of
a cyber threat yes so that does seem
scarier the issue with hackers is a
serious one and regardless of where the
hackers are from I don't know if they're
from North Korea or from the United
States or some other country it is scary
to know that if you have lacks
cybersecurity hackers can get into your
personal email account and leak all
sorts of embarrassing things right so we
have an issue with the government spying
on us but we also have an issue with you
know random private citizens that have
access to all this personal data what
are they gonna do with that data and a
lot of those emails that were leaked to
the press we're super sensitive super
embarrassing and I'm sure that alone
really freaked Sony out which is why
they made their initial decision not to
screen the right isn't that the grossest
part of this though that these hackers
whether you're for hacking or not or
anonymous or all that stuff or not these
were private emails that those people
were sending like we don't want our
private emails Hackney's oh so what do
you make of the like the sites like
Gawker and everything that were just
publishing all the emails I had a moment
yesterday where I got into the rabbit
hole of it by the way Randall Park who
plays kim jeong-hoon he's the he's
extremely funny yes movie yeah so I got
but I got into that rabbit hole and it
was actually on Gawker about sort of the
the Scott Rudin Angelina Jolie and I got
caught up in that and you start reading
the emails and of course it's
interesting at first to read private
emails of people in powerful positions
and it's like they're playing out a
scene from a movie about the industry
like a police people really talk that
but they're really talking this way sort
of how you'd write it
and then you realize I but about 17
minutes in and there's one story after
another and there's constantly more you
can read and is you know and as Angelina
Jolie really sort of self-obsessed and
an egotistical and maniacal and her
desire to get Cleopatra made and the big
fight if it's gonna they gonna make
Cleopatra or the Steve Jobs movie which
ones David Fincher gonna do it's so
exciting yeah and then you're like wow I
know I don't I don't care I don't care
and I I don't care not because I'm
smarter than this I'm interested in the
industry I don't care because it felt
Korean in the wrong way it felt like
watching amateur porn and not the good
kind of amateur porn but like in the
porn secret porn right hey this person
is they didn't mean for me to see this
and I don't even know whether they
believed it but we see it written and
then in a story on an official site and
we assume it's what they believe rather
than what they're saying to the person
they're emailing in order to get them to
come around to their point of view so
it's you know Angelina Jolie doesn't
need our help
but it felt unfair right her so actual
last points isn't that like where we
should be sort of angry is sort of at
the Gawker's of this like I get it and I
think you make a really good point that
people write things in emails that
aren't exactly first of it's not for a
public consumption but it's also not
always indicative of exactly how you
feel and you're playing a little game or
whatever so the companies and all the
websites that release the emails they
almost seem like the worst part of this
in a weird way yeah I mean I actually
have a lot of remorse because we covered
one of the email exchanges on The Young
Turks and I don't know why I had that
lapse of judgment but I did but that was
the wrong thing to do this is stolen
information stolen data stolen emails
and you shouldn't report on it if you're
AC and all that so I get I get yeah make
a news judgment each time and if in
those emails the ones you're talking
about and when I was on that show with
you and we took that video down and we
disagreed a little but it's funny at the
end of that video and I was like I'm
done with the story like I'm tired of
talking about you actually take the
video down yeah we took it down really
interesting it wasn't like we had some
compelling conversation that America
needed to hear anyway but not but
nonetheless that was that was the right
thing to do but like there's a point at
which we wouldn't have taken it down and
they this was the conversation where
they were sort of you know talk about
what movies the president would like
because he was black and embarrassing
and I don't think it rises to much of a
level of racism I don't think it's
demonstrative of anything except a
poorly exposed email chain but you know
but that said if they'd use the n-word
we wouldn't take the video down right so
you know and Donald sterling crossed
some line where we thought yeah that was
a private conversation but this becomes
relevant so you know we there is a point
at which these stories become newsworthy
into a country that these guys have
marketed and market and market us and
told us what we should like and told us
well we should spend our money on and
then they get caught a little bit well
there's some newsworthiness to that but
I'm basically with you is that it felt
it felt wrong but I can't get on
everybody there's news there and and how
it came out is I'm not sure they should
be they should be obsessed with by the
way I just did a search and I typed in
the and the interview that's that's
pretty impressed and Annika Lee if I
know anything about YouTube it's that
whoever is even paying for this thing is
going to watch about 20 seconds of it
not even get through the initial credits
and then start watching porn so there
you go you guys know about Menon ISM
it's sort of feminism for men and is
that a fair explanation feminism from
it's men that want to be empowered to be
men how's that sure that sounded pretty
good okay so the BBC did a report on
these guys it's this is a movement that
started about a year ago and it was
originally just a bunch of guys that
online were sharing jokes about men and
kind of making fun of the whole thing
but now it's sort of morph into this
group of men mostly online who are quote
expressing the difficulties of being a
man in the 21st century we've got some
some tweets and some photos about some
of the things that these guys have been
talking about I need men anism because
the movie Magic Mike promotes an
unrealistic expectation of how men's
bodies should look you know been please
fill this one with you it's tough
because if that's if he's kidding Bravo
well done pretty good if he's serious
what a gigantic jack bag like I mean you
don't so I don't know you know I don't
know but if it's serious then come on
man is this segment gonna end with you
taking your shirt off because you
haven't done it in a couple months
I'm already well underway all right
let's see what else we got we got some
tweets and some other pictures so here's
a series of tweets using the meninist
hashtag so sometimes it's meninist and
sometimes it's men and missed twitter so
why do men have to spend our hard-earned
money on dates when we can get asked out
picked up and fed I like free food too
so there they're trying to turn feminism
on its head why can't men ever get into
a club for free actually
look there are a lot of MRA people out
there that are extreme in their views
and I disagree with them there are some
that are actually reasonable and they
talk about unfair prosecutorial
standards for men versus women that can
be real quick explain what MRA is for
the men's rights activists right so I'm
willing to have a discussion about the
reasonable points that are made because
not all sexes are created equally when
it comes to certain situations right so
that's fine but that comment right there
about men not being able to get into
clubs for free I couldn't agree more
with that I actually hate when I go into
a club and it's like a titty fest and I
like I'm going there because I want to
socialize with other men I'm not going
there because I want to socialize with
other women
I'll do that somewhere else so yeah that
kind of does frustrate me if you don't
want a kitty fest you should stop going
all those lesbian bars if you want to go
to a club with a guy you're not getting
in unless you show up at like 9:30 right
because they just don't want guys in
there doesn't make any sense when you
and your Posse Jenk and Steve and the
rest of the crew all got together you
guys put on your nice black shirts and
then went to a club and you couldn't get
in right am i right you stand out there
looking like a bunch of Schmucks first
of all before I answer that question let
me just say that I want a titty fest you
know I I hear you that there's some do
people in the men's rights movement
occasionally stumble on to a good point
should men get into clubs no I don't
know it but it's not real like it's all
it's all about an idea that the people
who have power somehow want to feel like
victims so
and I hear you I would agree with a
couple of their points too but I would
accidentally stumble into agreeing with
a couple of Stalin's points like it's
all horseshit by the way those those two
tweets that we just show there those are
pretty insignificant things getting into
a club and being taken out on a date
like it's not systemic stuff go ahead
they absolutely are and you know I guess
my biggest argument against m-ras
would be just the idea that feminism is
a zero-sum game right so if women are
empowered and they're able to enter the
workforce and they're paid equally then
all of a sudden men are losing their
rights and men are screwed over and that
feminists want to violate men's rights
know women want simple things like I
don't know not getting raped or I don't
know have it making sure that there is
justice when there is sexual assault or
harassment at the work right so get paid
an equal amount for equal work right I
don't want to hear stupid arguments
about how women are the ones who get
knocked up and since we're the ones that
get pregnant well obviously we don't
take our job seriously we're gonna end
up leaving so we should get paid less no
that's a stupid [ __ ] argument there
are plenty of women out there that a
have no interest in having kids so you
can't just make that judgment from the
get-go and be like if they do end up
getting pregnant
a lot of women continue working not even
because they really want to because in
this economy you absolutely have to
right and then one other thing there's
another argument that oh look women are
getting better jobs than men are this
and that when more women are employed
than men these days you know look at the
the rates of employment in the United
States no you have to look at the types
of jobs women get hired at they don't
get high paying high level jobs as often
as men do right so if you want to have a
discussion you can't compare apples and
oranges you got to look at apples and
apples and in this case a lot of times
MRA people will ignore that you want to
have a discussion about prosecutions you
want to have a discussion about child
support you want to have a discussion
about matrimony
no not matrimony what's the thing that
you have to pay spousal support alimony
there is if you weren't married okay so
all those things are
all those things are legitimate topics
to discuss in a mature way but as I'm
sure you're gonna see in the comment
sections of this video a lot of people
are uninterested in having a mature
rational discussion about it there's
this very us-versus-them mentality and
also there's a lot of frustration about
guys who can't maybe have sex with
everyone that they want to have sex with
this notion that women only want bad
boys and women don't want me because I'm
a good guy usually good guys don't make
comments like that I'm full of
disappointment and it has nothing to do
with men and ISM more feminism and
you're not gonna get to have sex with
who you want to and you're not gonna be
able to get the club you want to and
you're not gonna be able to go to the
restaurant you want to and if you want
to go out with a girl you got a buyer
dinner maybe not you'll probably split
it with you
right that happens seems to but that's
not anything to do with feminism and
your last three minutes was like
impassioned and awesome because that's
what the issues of feminism are so don't
engage with them over whether they
should get in the club because what
they're trying to do is redefine
feminism and turn feminism into these
little things where a [ __ ] women just
want to have their way right but it's
not it's about what you said it's about
equal pay and equal rights and respect
and safety being able to address how you
want and go out and not think I hope
nothing happens to me so I I'm not gonna
engage with them on anything yeah well
actually I mean you both have pretty
much summed this up in a pretty
spectacular way let's just look it's
just like two more tweets just two so we
have a little bit of a broader sense of
the types of things why can't she open
the door for me again it's the type of
if they're kidding it's funny right
right you know I've been happy to send
that right and when we were looking at
the tweets on this just leave it up for
sec when we were looking at the tweets
on this I was having trouble figuring
out if these were jokes and I and
finally you can take bikini pics with
your friends but when I take shirtless
pictures with my friends I'm gay so
funny
he might be funny whoever
I don't know I mean I like shirtless
pictures movement of men well you know
what so there you go equality that's
what it's all about what do you think
let us know in the comments right down
below there really is no end to the
bottomless pit that is reality TV and to
prove this point in January TLC is
coming out with a show called my
husband's not gay let's take a look I
[Music]
like to say I've chosen an alternative
to an alternative lifestyle I'm
attracted to my wife for sure and I'm
definitely attracted to men too he's a
good-looking guy for sure well I'm
interested in men I'm just not
interested in men that's clear so are
they gay or not I get a little defensive
when somebody calls my husband gay the
whole act is against the teachings of
the gospel I want to marry a woman but I
don't know how to work out these
feelings I don't know how to tell you
this
but I'm attracted to men
you think sorry Dave
yeah please fill this one before I punch
someone you think maybe she had a clue
what was coming because there was a
camera there interface something might
be might not be just a normal day where
he tells her that he loves her you think
actually like they were up to saying
this is just I mean I hate reality
television it doesn't end every time we
think that it can't get worse it
actually does get worse and keeps
showing us just more twisted values and
blah blah blah but this like really
seems like the worst because the gay
thing I'm so over it
I think the country's over it nobody
wants to talk about anymore let's get
these last couple states to to fit and
then equality and blah and that's it and
big goddamn deal so to me this coming
out like what come on I actually don't
mind this reality show as much as others
because I think that it does shine a
light on a really serious issue which is
hiding who you really are because you
want to appease those in your religious
group yeah and when I watched the
trailer for that special I actually got
really upset at the women who know that
their husband is gay and they're
enabling this like denial of who they
really are by marrying them like if some
guy came to me and said hey you know
let's say I'm in love with him right and
he says look I'm super religious and I
really want to marry you but the reality
is I'm attracted to men I'd be like look
I love you too and this is devastating
but I'm not gonna have you marry me and
hide who you really are
be free right so so and I get it the
religion is what convinces these people
that they're doing the right thing
they're not doing the right thing this
is terrible
just flip it on its head imagine if you
as a straight person are forced to have
same-sex relations because your religion
says that's the right thing to do can
you imagine that
I mean I'm me is a straight woman can't
even imagine having sex with a woman
because I have no interest in women
right so doing that to appease anyone is
absolutely ridiculous yeah Presbyterians
who do that right exactly yeah let's see
they brought some for reprocessing oh
yeah I like Anna's point about that this
almost seems worse for the women than
for the men like the men are conflicted
there's this internal whatever and the
women are sort of taking it way they're
preying on it yeah it seems kind of
terrible I mean the religion is praying
upon it yeah the Mormons also have a
video out yes now about how not to
masturbate that's good advice
yeah you know this woman I love there
was in that clip she goes I get a little
defensive when someone calls my husband
gay well you're about to be on a show
called my husband yeah
it's gonna happen a lot more because
you're totally gay he's gay so why do
these people agree to do this is this
purely just everyone wants their 15
minutes and that's it like is that
really what this about or is do you
think this is really in their hearts
they're both the men are like I can beat
this and the women are like I can I do a
story on this in 1999 and maybe even
late 98 in Miami where I met Jake he was
not involved with this group but we did
it was this was this was the early days
at least of coverage of Exodus
international which was a leading if not
the leading gay conversion therapy and I
went to a meeting with these guys and
sat in and talked to the leader of the
group who you know was as gay as the day
is long but insisted no no not at all
but what he had done tragically was just
shut down he was like I've been celibate
for 23 years no no it's just my choice
you know and then there were these guys
and these guys we're strong I don't know
whether any of them were still somewhere
in relationship some just wanted to be
and it was just unbelievably painful one
guy got out right after the video and
called and was like hey he's gonna let
you know I turns out I'm just gay yeah
and I'm just gonna be gay and I'm
happier and you were like oh thank god
so god but I think that these guys were
sincere in their desire you know these
are guys whose faith is so strong in
this case it happens to be Mormonism but
we could in in and we could write in
almost any other faith their faith is so
strong and their their belief in their
in their religion is strong and the
condemnation from the people they admire
is so complete and without moderation
that they think this is the way I can do
this I mean you know you guys all the
time whatever you got something
life that you want to get rid of how
many times have you said I know it's
certainly true for me that I've said 250
times that was the last time I'm doing
this right now I'm gonna get my [ __ ]
together you know it's a gambling thing
I think yours actually a lot of things
yeah but gambling has been one actually
that one I don't mind
although the Warriors last night come on
okay so no could have seen that coming
so but so I believe it is sincere and I
believe they think they can do it if the
tragedy is that there's a the
alternative to their alternative for the
alternative is just you could probably
be happy and you could probably be happy
with Megan's husband right that's why I
don't want to be totally glib about this
because I do obviously feel a lot of
empathy for these guys and I was
closeted so I know what that's like but
why don't we see this with women what is
this like something here actually shows
me that there is something a little more
evolved with women because you do hear
about women all the time I know women
that in their mid 40s 50s they suddenly
get divorced and then they are openly
gay they're with other women yet with
men there definitely seems to be more of
this thing where you can like push it
down and of course that happens with men
too but it as a rule I think you see
more women accepting sexuality more I
think it has a lot to do with the
differences in male and female sexuality
they're not the same but I think a
bigger reason behind that is just to set
societal expectations and societal norms
so whenever you hear right-wingers talk
about gay marriage and you know they try
to like make a case against it they talk
about gay sex but they never talk about
gay sex between two women they talk
about gay sex between two men there's a
lot of stigma between men experimenting
with their sexuality whereas women are
free to experiment with it and it's
considered sexy and titillating right
that's why every girl in college can
make out and condemned scissoring you
know you know that's not that's not you
didn't talk about that that's not that's
not the issue yeah yeah it exactly what
you say Ana that there's still you know
women who experiment with other women
never ever and Google
thankfully have their femininity
questioned men who experiment with other
men are not met instantly you know in
the eyes of many and in the eyes of
maybe even still
most of society like we know you're
supposed to embrace it and it's okay but
come on he's not a man yeah so and that
that really has not changed very much
well this other rapid growth in gay
rights that that that stigma still holds
yeah I think to a large extent so last
point on this is that really because the
next step of this is that you're gonna
have to actually start seeing gay people
have some sort of affection on
television or in movies because we still
don't say everyone says I'm for gay
step4 blah blah blah but even on Modern
Family as I've mentioned a bunch on the
show they had a situation where one of
the guys has a fear of public displays
of affection it's an easy way to write
off I'm not I'm not judging the right
but it's the easy way to write off like
ah we don't have to do that that egg
factor as Marnie Frank called it so we
need that right like is that kind of the
next I think I think that with more and
more people accepting gay marriage and
understanding that gay rights is not
just a gay rights issue it's a civil
rights issue you're gonna start seeing
that reflected in media more and you
know it's it's a slow transition but I
definitely see that happening you seem
looking on HBO I feel like living it so
I didn't watch it I know people I know
they played the Golden Girls theme song
in the last episode people were very
excited there's those guys because I
mean they're not tied to anything it's
HBO but those guys aren't just gay those
guys are gay right yeah so I didn't know
this until we did a story on it last
week but apparently there is porn on the
computer machine and a new study in the
archives of sexual behavior is basically
proving that if you watch too much porn
especially for men it actually affects
your sexual behaviors let's take a look
at a little info from the study
researchers studied 487 male college
students they found that how often men
watched porn correlated directly with
how much they wanted to act out scenes
they'd seen the more they watched the
more they relied on pornographic
fantasies in the bedroom as well now
again because I did not know that there
was porn online until last week I did a
little research cuz we're a thorough
show here so I went to pornhub.com and
this is the front page of pornhub calm I
didn't type anything in this is the
front page pornhub calm so these as you
can see in the upper left there
these are the porn videos being watched
videos being watched right now and I
think this sort of illustrates the point
of the of the study I'll let you guys
handle a couple of these but doesn't
this got horny [ __ ] anal [ __ ] which one
do you want to see everyone come for
Cutie's yeah that's pretty mild Ben do
you want to pick a favorite there well
for I like I liked this is and this is a
surprise I hope I'm not out of school
here but I like corny [ __ ] anal [ __ ] -
better than better than the original
yeah because there was more horny [ __ ]
and and in the first one it was really
it was just anal [ __ ] which is fine
yeah but I thought they just disregarded
it but there were so there's a little
more of a story right just go back to
that for just a second I thought the
other interesting one was Muslim double
[ __ ] yeah Jen comes over and we Mia
Khalifa brings her big tits sometimes
she leaves them everywhere but this time
she decided to bring them along right
okay so yeah they're pure mature sexy
wife Lisa and thanks hubby that's not a
porn title cuz he stopped at Outback
Steakhouse on the way home and brought
dinner home she didn't have to cook it
go honey
thanks I'm gonna guess that as a married
man I've never been thanked in the way
that that woman probably thank her
anyway obviously we could do as ill you
stories and just laugh about the title
do you think but I do think it does
illustrate the point that they're saying
that this stuff is so accessible
obviously to all of us and we've all
watched it blah blah blah but do you
think it actually does [ __ ] with
people's expectations of sex
this study was really about men but even
for women I mean it really depends on
where you got your sex education from
right so if you grew up on porn and you
didn't have access to comprehensive sex
education you're more likely to think
hey this is what sex is really supposed
to be like which is why I'm such a huge
advocate for a comprehensive sex ed it
not only teaches kids what's right and
wrong it also teaches kids how to
protect themselves and all of that but
also you know I would make the argument
that a lot of adults know that what they
see in pornography is a fantasy right
there's some point out there that's you
know in a gray area for me you know
there's like rape porn incest porn all
of these like really really shady
categories and there have been studies
that prove that just because people
watch that type of pornography and they
fantasize about it doesn't mean that
they want to carry it over into their
actual sex lives right so again it
really depends on an age group it really
depends on how influential these people
are or I'm sorry how easily influenced
these people are it really depends so
that goes to the point that people
always say with video games violent
video games make you violent except
every study shows that that's actually
not the truth and I would get venture to
say that if you're watching some weird
porn it doesn't automatically mean that
you know you want to pee on someone or
whatever it is then take it what what
what are you doing over there Ben he's
actually doing research while we're just
calling yourself as a family show do you
think it changes do you think it changes
your expectations substantive believe
that study yeah I think it I think
certainly it does and I'm not sure that
that that all by itself is horrible yeah
you know if it makes people more
adventurous and tries things and frees
people Joe do stuff that they would have
thought was crazy great if it puts
pressure on people or sets an
unreasonable expectation then it's bad
but there's a lot of ground in the
middle there so I don't think it's bad
yeah do you guys think the final one
should you know too much if you lose
sense of reality then obviously it's
crossed into says the guy watching porn
while sitting here doing so she's very
uh she seems uh she seems that's horny
because the anal [ __ ] for like we all
talk look porn it's become normalized
which I actually think is good so people
don't have to it's not this shameful
whatever I think that's great but
anything there's something to be said
for not having full access to it then
what you know I do mean like I'm sure
when you were a kid you probably had to
find your dad's back a Playboy magazines
right I don't hang out a brother 12
years older that was the greatest yeah
yeah cuz he could go by him for years
well he just I just found his stack and
right yeah so but do you think that we
so the kids sort of like they're just
being hit with this immediately like
they can just go online like that I
guess that's the point your point about
education sort is yeah I mean look I was
hit with it immediately and I know that
I'm not really the demographic that
we're talking about right now but yeah I
had access to porn at a really young age
but again I'll
had access to really good sex education
look the only thing you can do to combat
the bad influences is make sure that
people are educated and unfortunately
we've moved away from that notion and we
have like these alarmist views when it
comes to things like pornography and I
love the point that been made if porn is
what yeah I do
well not the one about you like losing
it over the computer screen right now
but just the argument that look if
pornography is making you a little more
curious and adventurous in the bedroom
there's really nothing wrong with that
and it's important to have a
conversation with the person you're
having sex with to make sure that he or
she is comfortable with the things you
want to try out there you go and you
have a final thought yeah you know you
mentioned when when the the upsetting
parts of porn the you know the incest or
that and I was given a box of every guy
has this story some kind older gentleman
some friend who's been caught or
whatever has to give up his giant box of
porn and I got a giant box of porn
fairly late in life like when I was
living in Miami yeah
and included in this box was you put it
in and it was a it was incest it was I
mean they're actors but it was a father
having sex with his grown daughter and
the mother being upset so retaliating by
having sex with the son battleship yeah
yeah and it was incredibly disturbing it
was so disturbing that I had to mute it
sex robots are coming that's upon people
yeah we've talked a bunch about sex pots
before I'm a firm believer that in the
next 10 years or so people are gonna
start having sex with robots they're
probably doing it right now a French
artist drew something that I think is an
interesting depiction of what he thinks
at least sexbots are gonna look like so
this is actually CGI and basically he's
showing you that you know this thing cut
in half hopefully it'll have two halves
when you're having sex with it but just
showing that there's gonna be a lot of
parties and we're really that this is
what the future there's gonna be looking
at little brain right there this
computer in the brain you've got the
entry hole which has an arrow that's
nice just in case you don't know where
vaginas here you go this is where you
insert the penis above that appears to
be a target the target does seem
unnecessary there's some barcodes it
looks like on the bottom right there the
robot has artificial reproductive organs
and now if this isn't enough for you
we've got a video of a robot strimmer
let's take
[Music]
[Music]
all right so a couple things there she
seems to be bruised behind her legs
which seems weird why she wearing a mask
she's a robot
robots shouldn't have shame anyway I
just think this topic is interesting and
fun because it combines sex in the
future which i think is fun robot sex
will you have it when it comes I mean if
I need to have it I guess I will I mean
you have urges you have needs and
thankfully for now I'm okay right but I
don't have any problem with robot sex
there are people out there who you know
need sexual gratification in one way or
another and maybe this will help them
out so I'm all for it whatever
advancements in technology awesome
there you go so we just did the porn
story I mean it's sort of the just next
extension of that right like you know
it's there it's on your computer right
there and then next thing you know
you're banging a robot I'd be with a lot
of women so I've had plenty of robot
snacks huh okay all right that was sort
of I don't know if that was quite that
should have been low-fat or the I can we
go back to the CGI thing real quick yes
let's go back to the original image a
lot of like that you're like why doesn't
everyone have anal sex sometimes like I
mean they're both right there they're
just like I mean it's like there's no
like what's the element you see it like
that you're like why is it even taboo it
makes you wonder right also why is this
robot have so much machinery behind it
it could have been in a bed you know it
means but he drew it to have a lot of
other wires you know that that 78% of
stuff in the middle is all [ __ ]
that's just to drive the price up you
know there's like two things that make
it work that make it do this
which is pretty much the only thing that
woman yeah that's all that's all she
needs well that woman is not directly
related to that robot that's just as far
come with it with the dancing sex robot
do you think meta women are gonna do
this more because I think it's a
question it's a question because I think
by default right everyone's gonna think
men right you're gonna think man but I
also think there's women I know many
women they all are very frustrated with
men not all of them but like oh there's
a lot of single women not because the
men don't want to [ __ ] them they're
usually frustrated for others for others
but I feel like there's a lot of women
that just like sort of had it with men
at least maybe that's what I see around
here I think is a ridiculous one but
they're gonna be [ __ ] the robot but
your but your overall point is probably
true like here it is it will be
overwhelmingly men right but we would be
surprised at the number of women sure
some women will take advantage of it I
mean women love their vibrators so why
wouldn't they like this sex toy
it's definitely plausible but I think
you know men are probably gonna want to
have sex with a machine at higher rates
well I'm actually more interested in is
how many dudes look at that CGI image
and think like oh yeah right cuz it's
kind of right and I guess some of them
do like it well that'll probably become
a fetish in and of itself like I bang
robots I would be remiss if I didn't end
the segment asking one of my favorite
questions on the show which is what year
do you think the robots will take over
I'm not talking about the sex BOTS but
I'm a firm believer the machines are
coming they're on their way
what year do you think I'm gonna go with
I don't know 2050 didn't steai that's I
don't have any idea what I'm talking
about but Stephen Hawking just had his
voice box replaced you're not his voice
box but the thing that James format it's
much better and he was amazed at the
growth and artificial intelligence and
he essentially said hey look it's done
it's coming yeah basically taking over
society not as in like oh robots are
gonna kill us but they take over your
jobs they take over certain elements of
society that we need humans for right
now and that could actually lead to the
destruction of a lot of different things
yeah
but you know what the one thing that
robots can't replace is the talking
human mind that we've given you here
today well not well that's not
necessarily true okay I would totally
watch a robot talk show we got like two
or three of them on The Young Turks okay
thank you Dan and thank you to bend and
Merry Christmas everybody and Happy New
Year and all that good stuff and we'll
be back
[Music]